thanks for all your support we really
appreciate it thanks a lot for all the
all the great donations if you're in LA
let's get a beer or enjoys Thunderbird
wine thank you for coming to reason.com
for supporting reason and for your
fabulous comments thank you so much
donors for all you do for us it really
means a lot we couldn't do what we do
without you getting back to work do
thank you for helping us achieve this
historic event of achieving over 500 new
friends of Liberty thank you for your
support reasontv says thanks thank you
for your support of reasons web athan
i'm sure you love the great content on
reason calm and reason TV but you've
also supported the work we do with those
few politicians out there who are
actually trying to make government
smaller we testify at mind-numbing
legislative hearings so you don't have
to thank you for your support of reason
thanks appreciate it thank you thank you
thank you thank you for your support
thanks everyone I'd like to dedicate
this bag of chips to everyone who
donated Thank You reason donors for your
generous support hi reason donors thank
you for supporting what we do thanks for
supporting the reason web athan please
keep watching recent TV thank you
raising donors for all your very
generous support thanks for your support
reason owners and remember if you can
dream it you can do it hey reason donors
thanks very much for giving us your
money I keep trying to look like nick
gillespie but they tell me I'm not
pulling it off thanks for your support
of reason we appreciate